[Music]
Carroll and Bethany something has gone
down between them yes something has I'm
not sure Carroll is excited to see me as
she used to be some people you know some
people are long to tongue and the other
people some people like like this think
about it and slowly let it come out this
year she's a little more lung to tongue
instead of thinking about it she's like
actually that's I think she just got
very engaged and she just is she's a
very strong woman and she likes to speak
the truth you know listen they had a
very strong really a very close
relationship but sometimes as I said to
both of them things change doesn't mean
the friendships over they just take on a
different you change life changer and
they'll figure it out and come back
together it may just be a little
different
okay so there's you think there's hope
there for us I mean no one died you know
no one did anything they had and and at
the end of the day they'll work through
it and it will just settle were you
surprised that that happened or were you
waiting for
I was surprised okay is was there one
incident that we're going to see or was
it slow no okay
it really does unfold over like eight
episodes so for me to just even sit here
as they this was the one thing it wasn't
does it a disservice I think what's
interesting is to watch how the other
relationships develop yeah it is
interesting
the whole seasons interesting everything
we're together you're aggressive with me
that's not the case honey it is don't
call me honey some viewers and fans have
said watching this Carolyn Bethenny
think kind of play off that maybe for
one of them it's time they leave the
group do you feel that way I think it
looks fantastic I think we're all strong
characters we have a great dynamic very
comfortable around each other
[Music]